pour faire connaissance
mon cher jean carmet je vais me
permettre de te poser quelques questions
auxquelles je souhaite que tu ne me
répondent sans fard ton premier souvenir
c'est quoi
ma première respiration peut-être hui on
dit que j'ai une grande mémoire tout le
monde disait dans mon enfance que j'irai
loin parce que je me souvenais de la
première c'est ma première fugue c'est à
trois ou quatre ans où il ya plus
exactement c'était la recherche d'un
bruit de bruit d'un train qui passait à
port-bou les mois comme j'habitais
bourgueil d'avoine passée par là et on
me raconter toujours les exploitent ce
train qui était le nôtre est hérité
c'était un train cela veut dire que tu
mets beaucoup les trains et j'ai voulu
voir de près comment cet effet alors je
me suis habillé puis je suis parti j'ai
j'ai fait trois kilomètres à pied on m'a
rattrapé au bout de trois kilomètres
c'était ma première fugue ta première
basse ma première baffe sa du cdu est
très jeune
j'en ai pris beaucoup j'ai été élevé à
la barre m'enfin pas cruellement mais la
barse la baffe et la pompe rilke août
tombe dans le cul ça j'ai connu beaucoup
jusqu'à temps que ce court plus vite que
mon père mon premier rêve c'est mon
premier rêve il a été provoqué par un
ami de mon père qui s'appelait et mid
est qui
rêver nous de nous faire faire un voyage
en amérique ray alors ils avaient
inventé pour nous un à une embarcation
qui était un fut coupée en 2 auquel on
avait mis une voile
ah oui ça 7 juillet mais il ya eu
l'avion aussi oui et c'est un avion qui
faisait la vitrine pour les fêtes de
noël chez un marchand de nouveautés de
bourgueil et que on vous avait donné à
émuler à toi pour l'équipe et de mettre
un moteur un moteur est qu'un élastique
qui vous permettrait de traverser
l'atlantique
ton premier amour mais mes grands
parents avaient une petite maison à la
campagne près de tours où ils allaient
passer les vacances l'été quand il
faisait très chaud à tour et il y avait
un jardin juste en face c'est nous il y
avait des émanations d'odeurs une odeur
que je ne connaissais pas parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de pieds de lavande à la
maison et cette odeur m'attirait et
cette odeur m'attire et si bien que je
m'approchais de cette maison et j'ai vu
une ravissante petite fille qui allait
très bien avec l'odeur de la lavande
voit la politique c'est très joli ça
c'est très poétique mais ya pas eu le
choix et qu'on charcutière non car la
charcutière de bourgueil je la regardais
d'abord parce que je l'avais une grande
admiration parce mag pour ce magasin
parce qu'il y avait une une tenture à ce
magasin quand pour cacher les produits
et pour éviter qu'ils fondent à la
chaleur et ça représentait une peinture
à l'huile qui représentait une chasse à
courre ou une face au au sanglier
d'aller admirer cette peinture parce que
c'était de la peinture à l'huile et xav
et une certaine réputation et quand ça
s'est levé il y avait là la charcutière
qui était très belle très bien habillée
maquillée c'était la seule
vraisemblablement qui se maquiller dans
ce pays et elle avait un une très très
belle poitrine avec 1
une blouse amidonné qui lui donne une
forme roussin moi qui n'avais aucune
idée de ce que c'est et une paire de
seins à l'époque j'étais plus encore
fascinés par les seins de la circulaire
que par la chasse au sanglier ta
première cuite
vous savez que moi je suis né dans un
pays devint donc la cuite est une chose
je ne dirais pas de c'est pas une chose
obligatoire mais le grand but c'était de
d'emmener un parisien dans les caves et
de le faire ressortir dans un état très
très très avancé alors m'est arrivé une
fois d'accompagner des parisiens avec
mon père
il n'était pas surveillée j'ai vu avec
eux 1
j'ai bu comme eux et quand je suis sorti
de là j'étais cuit comme les parisiens
et mon père était fou de rage et de
honte parce qu'il va dire il ne tiendra
pas le co direction de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus